Only men. Predators is patriarchy.
Y'all don't see that men are not predators.
What's a predator?
A predator is someone that hunts prey.
And what do they hunt pray for?
They hunt prey for food.
And more importantly,
they are not hunting the same species.
They're hunting a different species.
Your husband, when he goes on his boy trip and goes and,
you know, gets a deer, and it feeds you for the winter,
that's a predator.
That's a predator.
Calling men who victimize women and children predators
minimizes the severity of what they're doing,
because what it does is it ties their actions to their nature.
It is not in man's nature to victimize
the female counterpart of his own species.
If he is a lion and you are the lioness, and he hunts.
Actually, I think maybe the lioness hunts,
but for the sake of this,
the food, the deer,
the other species,
and brings it back to feed you and the children,
that is a predator.
A lion that terrorizes his own village and his own species
and the females in it
is a monster. He is a freak of nature,
unfit for the company of his fellow species.
He is.
I don't know. We need to come up with a better name than predator,
because that's not a predator.
That's a monster.